hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're going to be
going over a cool little trap the
Hollister trap and it derives from the
blackmart Deemer gambit in the black
barty myrrh game it starts out with pawn
to d4 pawn to d5 these are the main
lines it can transpose a few different
ways but pawn to e4 offering up this
gambit on e4 from here blacks gonna take
on e4 and whites gonna play a
development move Knight to c3 and at the
same time attacking this pawn on e4
Black's gonna respond with his own
development move Knight to f6 I always
wanted to belk your Knights to the
center at the same time trying to defend
this pawn on e4
now why it's gonna continue the main
line with pawn to f3 weaken is weakening
his King side so more than likely he's
gonna castle on the Queen side from here
blasts gonna take on f3 and White's
gonna offer up the Ryder gambit with
Queen takes on f3 and this allows the
Queen to come to d4 now white is down
two pawns in material but black may fall
into a very familiar trap that we're
gonna take a look at the hollister trap
this is actually a very aggressive and
very good line for white because he has
a lot of attacking potential from here
White's gonna play Bishop to e3 and the
Queen has to go somewhere and a lot of
times if a black player hasn't played
this too often he'll play Queen to b4
thinking that the white would like to
castle on the king stop excuse me on the
Queen side and he already knows that we
can't play rook to be one to defend this
B to pawn because we want to cap on the
Queen side and we won't play pawn to b3
the fin
because we'll lose our knight on c3 and
so he knows that if we castle on the
Queen side then he can bring his Bishop
to g4 pinning down our queen to the our
rook on the one and blacks gonna just
continue to mount up more and more
material since he already has a to pawn
advantage a lot of times if he can trade
off this rook for his Bishop that's
gonna be ample material for him to win
the game pretty easy but this is
actually the trap that we want him to
fall into after he plays his Queen to b4
we're gonna continue with our playing
castle on the Queen side and remember we
want to castle on the Queen side one for
King safety but at the same time more
importantly we want to bring her knight
excuse me our rook to d1 we really want
this full D open file to be open for a
rook cuz it's gonna open a lot of
attacking lines for our rook and this
King can't move as we attack the King
the entire game it's gonna be really
hard for him to develop his pawn and
it's really gonna be hard for him to
move his dark squared bishop so as long
as we can attack this King he can't move
on this D file which is really what we
want so as long as we can start to
attack the King it's gonna be very hard
for him to not lose the game so from
here we'll continue more times than not
if he does play Queen to b4 he's gonna
play Bishop to g4 and from here we don't
care that our queen is being attacked
instead we are going to play Knight to
b5 and this is a brilliant move here if
he were to be a [ __ ] and take our Queen
here then he's gonna lose the game with
Knight takes on c7 and this is checkmate
there's no way for his knight to go and
he can't take this knight here his King
can't move because our
rook here on d1 is attacking so he can't
do that and there's a few other options
that you may see keep in mind at the
same time we are attacking his queen so
he's gonna have to do something there's
a few things that you may see one of the
most common is you may see Knight to a
six and what this does is it defends
this pawn on c7 but from here we can
bring our Queen and take on b7 right
away and at the same time we are still
attacking this pawn on c7
so if he tries something fancy we can
come here take on at c7 and at the same
time we have a discovered attack on the
Queen on b4 so it's being defended right
now by the the knight on a six but that
night on a six is going to have to take
our knight on c7 or is gonna lose the
game so from them we can easily take its
Queen so from here you may see the Queen
come to e4 and this is a very important
move because keep in mind at the same
time not only are we attacking this c7
pawn but we're also attacking this rook
on a eight and he can't move his rook to
c8 because from here we can take this
knight on a six we have a completely
winning game he can't he would like to
take our rook on d1 but he can't do this
because now we can take his rook on c8
and that's a good game for black so a
lot of the things that black would like
to do he can't do that and since we've
already taken his knight here on a six
all his opportunities are falling out
the window so c8 for his rook is going
to be a bad move his best move
excuse me after b7 is to try last
attempt with Queen to e4 and what this
does he's trying to trade off Queens
here trying to somehow not lose this
game at the same time trying to defend
his rook on a a from here though we can
just take the knight on a6 and from here
he can take our Bishop on e3 which is it
looks on the surface like it's okay for
black we are now going to bring our
queen
excuse me our King to be won and now the
Queen's gonna bring his blacks gonna
bring his queen to c5 and from here
we're going to either develop our Knight
to f3 or if you want to play an even
more aggressive move
you can play Queen to b7 as you can see
here White has a lot of attacking moves
he's attacking this rook on a8 and at
the same time he's double attacking this
pawn on c7 and there's a lot that black
really has to look at and there's not
much that he can do here from here if he
takes our rook on d1 then we can take
his rook on AAA and pretty much he lost
the game good game black here
if he moves his Queen to d7 here we can
now bring our knight back to c3 we're
gonna have a pretty easy game from here
on out we can start to develop our minor
pieces and bring our other rook into the
action as you can see here the material
is about even he's up one pondan
material but as you can tell our pieces
are a lot more active and as king is
wide open in the very middle of the game
so this is gonna be a very good game for
white and this is if he plays perfectly
if he falls into that trap early on and
plays his Bishop to g4 trying to pin
down our Queen it's gonna be very hard
for him to do anything but lose the game
there are a few other options that you
may see in the game a lot of times we'll
go ahead and get into it again after we
bring to f3 and he takes
and we bring our Bishop to e3 and we
castle on the queenside he brings his
bishop down if we bring our knight to b5
a lot of times you'll see him right away
try to get his pawn out of the way and
try to give his King a little bit of
room so you may see pawn to e5 which is
a noble attempt but from here we can
come in and play our Knight to c7
attacking the King and as we already
talked about he can't move down this D
file because of our rook this rook on d1
is so important the entire game because
it really minimizes where the King can
go now from here the only move that
black has is King to e7 and from here we
can just bring our Queen to b7 and we're
already attacking this rook on a 8
there's nothing that black can do to
prevent us from taking this and we're
just going to continue you up in the
material his King is out in the open
we're just gonna continue to gobble up
pieces if he tries to last-ditch effort
and takes our Queen on b7 then we can
bring our Bishop to c5 checkmate there's
no way for him to go and this would be a
pretty awesome way I think to win the
game because he has so many these pieces
but there's nothing he can do he can't
take our bishop and he can't move
because of our Knight and he can't move
on this d5 because of our rook so keep
this in mind if you do play it another
thing you do want to take a look at is
if he doesn't fall into the trap anytime
you do play a trap you want to be aware
that he may not fall into it so if we
continue along the lines of the trap and
he takes on f3 and we do play f3 with
our queen and he does come down and
capture with his queen after we play
with Bishop to e3 the best move that he
can do is Queen to g4 not putting his
Queen on b4 trying to attack this pawn
at the same time working and continue
castle on the Queen side remember this
is
important with this trap we're giving up
this pawn on d4 early on so that our
rook can nicely sit here on the deef
I'll just aim down the attacks on the
black King now from here if we take a
look at it if black were to capture on
f3 and we recapture with our Knight now
white is down to pawns in material but
at the same time we have a lot of
attacking ideas if you just look at the
setup here Black has one Knight
developed to f6 we have both of our
Knights developed to the center we have
a bishop developed we have our King side
safety castled on the Queen side and we
have a rook nicely aligned on the D file
so although we're down to pawns and
material we have a lot of aggressive
lines and this is going to be a very
good and fun game for white as he can
use his creativity to put a lot of
attacks on the black King and the black
King is gonna be running around the game
instead of developing like normal if
white plays it correctly so these are
some of the things you want to take a
look at when you play the Hollister trap
if he does fall for it which you'll see
a lot of times you have a devastating
attack but even if he does it you still
have a lot of attacking lines and it's
gonna be a very aggressive aggressive
play from you so keep this in mind play
this let me know how it goes
I've had a lot of fun with it Experion
experimenting with it so let me know how
you guys do with it as well
if you haven't already please subscribe
to the channel and let me know what you
guys think if you haven't checked out
the website the chess website calm
pretty easy and thanks for watching I'll
see you guys in the next video